depuis hier ses salariés ont dû enfiler
gants et masqu de protection mardi une
de leurs collègues présentait des
symptômes de la grippe A elle est depuis
en arrêt de travail consignée à domicile
dans cette entreprise de recouvrement de
créances c'est donc tout un dispositif
qui a été dès lors mise en place outre
le port de masque FFP2 et de gants en
latex la climatisation a été coupé afin
de limiter la propagation du virus et du
liquide hydroalcoolique a été distribué
au 250 employés ici la grippe A on s'y
prépare depuis le printemps donc on
avait commandé 200 boîtes de 100 masques
donc pour les trois sites de
l'entreprise et 1500 masques FFP2 donc
après ont été dispacer ces matchs sur
les autres sites deentreprise donc à
Paris à ne ville enferin en fonction de
l'effectif présent sur ces sites pour la
direction pas question de cesser
l'activité notamment sur ces plateformes
d'appel les déplacements Inter dont les
bureaux lillois et parisiens de la
société seront limités ainsi qu'au sein
même du siège ici à tour où les
collaborateurs doivent le plus possible
éviter les changements d'étag des
mesures astraignantes mais suivies par
l'ensemble des salariés hier matin bien
sûr il y
avait un petit moment comico étonné les
gens dis est-ce que c'est bien
nécessaire de mettre un masque et cetera
bon je dans la journée tout le monde
tout le monde a absolument jouer le jeu
bon c'est un peu
contraignant il fait un peu chaud sous
ses masques c'est pas agréable de pas
avir la clime mais enfin bon je pense
que tout le monde prend ses précautions
dans un esprit de de solidarité
vis-à-vis de ses collègues et de
prévention pour que ceci se passe le
mieux du monde pour tous c'est pour les
familles bien sûr un dispositif
antigripe a qui sera maintenu jusqu'à
samedi dans la soirée si d'ici là aucun
autre cas de contamination n'est avéré
l'activité du site pourra reprendre
normal allemand dès lundi matin